okay welcome to everybody
I'm Nathan Dan
co-chair and part of the goal of this
conference is to showcase some of the
great work happening in the Los Angeles
data community I'm really happy to
introduce one of the last two keynotes
who both of them are Los Angeles locals
doing great great things yet in very
different industries Ben Welsh is the
editor of the Los Angeles Times data
desk a team of reporters and computer
programmers in the newsroom who who work
to collect organize analyze and present
large amounts of information Ben is also
co-founder of the California civic data
coalition an open-source network of
developers working to open up public
data Ben is also creator of past pages
an arc idea an archive dedicated to the
preservation of online news Ben has
worked at the Los Angeles Times and
since 2007 before working at the Times
been conducted data analysis for
investigative projects of the Senator
Center for Public Integrity in
Washington DC projects he has
contributed to have been awarded
numerous prizes including the Pulitzer I
met Ben through an education program he
was leading through the knight
foundation python for data journalists
analyzing money in politics the
educational program this program taught
journalists how to use Python pandas to
Purdue notebooks and related Python
tools to help investigate money in
politics
another interesting fact I was just
browsing through github through Ben's
github and I noticed that he has made it
accepted contributions to pandas Jupiter
lab Altair probably several others as a
conference chair I'm excited to hear
about some of the tools that he that
this community supports and maintains
are being utilized by the LA Times
please join please welcome me in joining
Ben wells
hello how are you guys good good
it took a minute to get set up because I
tried to plug my Linux computer into
this fancy system you can guess how well
that went
we're back on the Apple so this is me
Ben Welsh like you heard this is what my
wife calls my Bible salesman photo which
is definitely not a compliment
I go by pale wire online that's my
handle on most things that's a long
story I mean all the slides that I'm
gonna walk through here today are
available for you online at this URL
Whois data desk la tems Whois data desk
if you go there you can follow along you
can breeze ahead you can share it with
somebody else and also I'll point out in
the lower corner here on the right will
be little hyperlinks that will link off
to every example I show cuz I'm gonna go
through a lot of stuff really fast and
just to try to keep it interesting and
if there's anything you want to check
out you just stop go to this link and
just look for the little blue link in
the corner okay you should be able to
find it so I'm back at my first slide I
had the old LA Times headquarters
downtown that's actually not where we
work anymore the LA Times has recently
moved to El Segundo which I'm taken to
calling gundo and so if you drive down
take the 105 to LAX you'll see a new
office that's where the database sits
every day on the 6th floor they're doing
our job and what the heck do computer
programmers do in a newsroom well they
do a couple things and I'm gonna walk
you through them alright and give you
examples of each the first thing we do
and we do a lot of this is we take data
and for some reason this is like the
emoji for data no one's ever explained
it to me you know what if you know what
the heck that is please let me know I'm
told it's a database right we take data
big chunks of information as our raw
material they're our input right and
then we process those data and that data
and we turn it into stories right and so
that's one big thing the data test does
is we turn databases into news and that
means we write code so even though I
went to journalism school and I got
started in TV news and other people in
our team went to journalism school for
the most part or were librarians there
were other things we all write computer
but and that includes Python like this
and a lot of other things but we still
also write in English so even though
we're computer programmers that doesn't
mean we're just like nerds in a cubicle
in the corner and we don't participate
in making and telling stories we also
still do that too so let me tell you a
story of how that went but before we go
here's some late-breaking news numbers
in the news there's a big number tonight
in the news does anyone know what it is
1.6 billion is the number in the news
today and that's because there will be a
Mega Millions jackpot for that amount
all right and through this speech I'm
going to be doing some quick trivia
questions some easy some hard and if you
shout out the correct answer you will
win one ticket in tonight's Mega
Millions lotto for 1.6 billion dollars
all right and should you win should you
win I don't expect anything all right
but you should consider maybe writing a
check to numb focus if you have 1.6
billion you might need the tax shelter
ok so let's start with an easy one this
will be the easiest one what's on this
map California who was it
one ticket come collect all right
there you are sir all right so that's an
easy one the Maps gonna zoom in a little
closer
it's now here what's this on this map no
nope what Santa Barbara County who said
it come get your ticket
okay so California has 58 counties I
know you guys are numbers people so
there's 58 counties one of which is LA
County - the best County but maybe
second best if we're being generous
might be Santa Barbara County which is
just up the coast a little north of
where we are now he says it's pretty
cool I can't disagree and then if we
zoom in a little closer here's a tougher
question within Santa Barbara County if
we zoom in on this area right here we're
gonna see that does anybody know what
that is hmm no no
no no no no
so there's Gaviota here's your hint
right Gaviota is over here and you just
keep going what's that it's something
ranch you can't win twice all right so
we're moving on that it is actually
Hollister ranch does anyone know what
Hollister ranch is this is a picture of
it it's a it's a subdivision in the
mountains just west of Santa Barbara
City that is private it has private
roads and about a hundred and thirty
houses including mansions populated by
people like James Cameron and the
founder of Patagonia and Jackson Browne
and they have a beautiful subdivision
with many many rich mansions and they
have actually closed off the roads from
the public including access to the
public beaches like this beautiful one
here and if you read the LA Times you
can read stories by my colleague Rosanna
who writes about environment and coastal
access here in California
and you'd receive stories like this like
she did recently and if you were to read
that you would learn that you know in
California the public has a right to
access the beach right it's the beaches
public property but in this case the
road that goes to the beach is not right
and the residents of Hollister ranch
have spent the last several decades
trying to make sure that those roads
don't get open to the public and the
only way you can really get to the beach
is on horseback or by kayak all right
and one of those people who's attempted
to kayak to Hollister ranch on a few
occasions is our city columnist Steve
Lopez who writes a lot about coastal
access and he thinks that stuff like
that should be opened up and he's
curious to learn more about elite places
like Hollister ranch and how they're run
so after Rosanna did this story recently
Steve got a tip and then Steve called me
on the phone and he said Ben have you
ever heard of something called the
Williamson Act I said Steve I have no
goddamn clue what you're talking about
and like any good scientist I went to
Google and then to Wikipedia right and I
looked it up when I read this and it
says the Williamson Act is a law in the
state of California that says that
certain agricultural lands that are
certified by local county authorities
so there's 58 different ways of doing it
right are able to be designated as
agricultural something or other on
state law and then given guess what a
hefty property tax break right and
Hollister ranch even though it's a
subdivision said his tip it still also
classified as an agricultural because
there's a cattle operation run by two or
three residents that are allow their
cows to wander around everyone else's
property whether they participated in or
not
sounds like a pretty good tip but how do
you check that kind of thing out well
this is where data can help so Steve and
I went to the County Assessors website
and then we could actually called up a
guy who works in the appraisal division
there and we said do you guys track any
of this you know like we got this tip we
heard this thing is it really true what
is it what's about and the guy started
walking us through the Assessors website
and on this website there's a database
and if you're like in our business on
the outside of these big data systems
unlike say hunter Owens earlier from LA
City who's on the inside if you're on
the outside like us you're almost kind
of fumbling around we don't know what
got dated the government keeps and what
it released in there and who has it or
da-da-da-da-da but what we love our web
forms right cuz web forms signify
there's a database and we started
interviewing this guy and we're like
well what about like James Cameron's
house or whoever just like pick one the
guy came up with a parcel number which
is the unique ID for a property you
punch it in there and he pointed out
this site to us you know and this is
what's called the value notice which is
published online for every property in
Santa Barbara County and if you qualify
for the Williamson Act someone someone
perhaps anticipating what Steve Lopez
would like to do right had created this
table that exists on every parcels page
which says hey under normal property tax
rules and is the state of California a
property is assessed under what's called
prop 13 right under normal property tax
rules this property would be assessed at
seven hundred and fifty thousand dollars
and it's property tax would be one point
one percent of that approximately right
but because it was called agricultural
and sorry this is kind of grainy here
that number went down from 750,000 to
only three hundred and thirty eight
thousand whoa that cut this person's
property tax in half right
I wonder if everybody in Hollister ranch
whether they participate in ranching or
not get that kind of benefit right well
how do we figure it out so that there's
Hollister ranch so we go back to this
map you may have noticed that this map
didn't look as nice as the previous ones
because those other ones came from
Google this one came from Mike huges as
ugly as it is it is a beautiful tool
open-source software that allows you to
take electronic map files called
shapefile so you guys know all this
stuff I normally talk to journalists
I'll just stop with that
QGIS this is a file I got from guess
what the county surveyors website where
I was nosing around and hey there's a
shapefile that has all the subdivisions
when I looked in the attributes I saw
hey these are marked as Hollister ranch
then I knows around a little more and I
found they have an FTP online oh my gosh
and the FTP has every parcel right okay
this is I get excited guys and then I
put that in my queue just so now here's
every parcel in Santa Barbara County and
there's house to ranch if now if I'm
going to do this analysis I need to like
cookie-cutter these guys out right back
when I first started doing this stuff I
might have tried to use the queue just
plug in waited 45 minutes it would have
crashed in I mean I would have bitched
and moaned or whatever but now thanks to
y'all in my Jupiter notebook I import
geo pandas alright have you guys have
seen geo pandas it's like pandas with
the geospatial stuff so I'm able to take
one shape file of all the parcels and
another of the subdivisions filter the
subdivisions down do a spatial join get
the subset of 136 or whatever parcels
and house tranche
sorry but then you may have noticed if
you look carefully at this file that was
in the FTP it had AB suffix underscored
no owners so I was able to confined all
the parcels in Hollister ranch but I
didn't know who owned him and if we're
gonna write the story we got to know
which ones James Cameron and which ones
nada
so I emailed the guy names have been
redacted to protect the innocent okay so
I emailed the guy at the county and I
said dude where are the
can I have the owners what's that uh I
should be using the clicker anyway and
so here's the email he sent me back and
you know this stuff is public record
right the data should be out there but
this is the kind of thing that happens
in real life when you're like doing what
we do the guy says well actually Ben we
cannot send you the ownership records
and they cannot be published online
because there's a state law that says
that public officials names and
addresses cannot be published over the
Internet
everybody else is in trouble and our
interpretation of that law
administratively is that no addresses or
owners can be published online at all
right and this is the sort of thing that
just like makes me drives me crazy
and as we accumulate as we try to ask
for data like this from different
government offices what we often find is
they often have different
interpretations of these laws and
depending on who you're talking to
you're going to get different stuff
their office isn't Santa Barbara I'm an
El Segundo oh my god they want me to
drive up there pay them 50 bucks to get
a CDR and drive back down and do the
merge right and so unlike all you guys
I'm not very nice so then I just start
banging the table and you can see I was
like so angry writing this email I
accidentally put a question mark at the
end of the first sentence which I didn't
even mean to do but but after I sent it
I was like yeah I did mean that you know
I mean even though it was totally
accidental there's like a typo blah blah
blah and so then we begin a process
where we're banging on the table we
begin calling all the politicians hey
give us the owners ultimately I did have
to cut him a check which I charged to
our new billionaire owner and they sent
it to me via Dropbox file requests which
is an awesome feature by the way and
then now that I had all the owners I had
a complete dataset of all the parcels in
Hollister ranch and who owns them but I
needed those value notices that were in
that weird webpage they didn't have the
database for that so here comes my
Jupiter notebook again right and some
like a scraper now web scraping is like
if we had a conference like this for
news nerds like in my robe which we do
web scraping is like the number one most
popular thing everybody loves this this
is of two tool and feature in Python
that is absolutely crucial to what we do
because so much data is on the internet
but not in a format that we can like get
at and how we want and so tools like
this like requests and beautifulsoup
which I love and other things are really
important and just to prove that I put
this up just to prove I'm not totally a
bad guy
I did put a user agent letting them know
who
why was and there's like a little time
where it sleeps ten seconds between
requests I'm not a bad guy right and so
then we downloaded that parse the data
out merged it and at the end of the day
ultimately the data analysis that we did
is is seen like in in maybe 10 or 10 10
or 15 lines of Python and it's it's math
that's so simple that I'm almost
embarrassed to show it to this room you
know what I mean because you guys are
doing all this really sophisticated
stuff but at the end of the day after we
had been able to get all the parcels and
all the value notices for the hundred
and thirty whatever parcels it really
was just calculating the difference in
the property tax break right for all
those properties summing it up right and
then calculating basically the
percentage you know and so then roughly
speaking the property tax of all these
millionaires who live in these huge
coastal elite mansions and deny you
access to the beach is a 50% property
tax break which adds up to about two
million dollars last year and will
continue to add up each year and then
that ultimately comes out as this
because you know you or I could maybe
read this but it lacks context your
mother probably doesn't read Python code
I know mine doesn't but my mother
definitely reads Steve Lopez and so we
then took that data analysis and put it
into a relatively traditional form which
was Steve's column and he sort of
unfurled the the analysis and all the
context and this was in last Sunday's
newspaper and so that's a way and this
column is an example of how all the open
source tools that you guys work on and
that we depend on in our business end up
creating kind of a pretty traditional
kind of like investigative story right
and and but we do other things that
aren't so traditional that are that
follow the same pattern
Oh for this conference actually here's I
created a new repository which we just
open sourced over the weekend which has
all of the Jupiter notebooks we've
released for stories like this including
Hollister ranch if you go to data desk
slash notebooks on github you could find
every single one of them only some of
them buy me a lot of them by my
colleagues as well but another example
from the past week of us taking data and
turn it into news involve this guy pop
quiz who is he okay you can't win for
that
- easy even I you know I love a better
basketball one and so Andy Andy Roberson
who's on our team she had been charged
with creating for LA Times comm a Lakers
roster to help our readers get to know
all the different people on the Lakers
and had little videos for each of them
and their BIOS and stats and stuff about
how tall they are and where their foot
college they went to and all that stuff
and she made a really nice page but we
kind of felt like oh I could use like a
little more data could use like a little
more like oomph going on in the page and
so that's where Ryan Manassas came in
who's sitting right back over there and
and he went and developed a data set
that had Ryan just correct me where I
get this wrong basically the location on
the court where all the players in the
NBA shoot from and how well they shoot
and how many shots they made from each
of those positions he then fed that into
a different style of notebook which is
called an observable notebook who here
has seen observable notebooks he got to
check out this website observable hq.com
it's by Mike Bostock the creator of d3
and Jeremy Ashkan ashed creator of a lot
of other cool programming stuff and
they're attempting to create a
JavaScript notebook that's basically in
the cloud that is is already a
competitor to stuff like Jupiter and is
an incredible product for for really
rapidly creating interfaces and
visualizations from data in like
cutting-edge JavaScript I would really
recommend checking it out and Ryan was
able to with just a little bit of code
in this notebook take that data file we
looked at before wired into a d3 hex bin
system and create different shot charts
for every player in the NBA showing
where they shoot from and how they made
it we did a little bit of work to style
it out in the Lakers colors week sport
the SVG from that we move it into the
website and then here for each player
when you click on them you get not just
the bio and the video you get also their
shot chart right so there's Brendan
Ingram and so this is a case where we're
using that data to help make something
that's untraditional it's not a
newspaper article right it's like a web
feature it'll never appear in the print
paper and our team tries to really do
both of those things so here's LeBron
Jameses shot chart right
LeBron he's good alright you may have
heard all right next quiz who's shot
chart is this
JaVale McGee who said it there he is
JaVale [ __ ] looks pretty good so far
this year yeah he I've been impressed
especially defensively offensively he's
got room to improve all right so we
don't just turn turn data into news we
also often do the reverse this is the
second type of thing we do and so I want
to walk you through a couple examples of
this and that might sound glib just
flipping it around but I'm serious so
here's an example it's a serious example
so when I first started at the LA Times
in 2007 there was the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan were going pretty hot and
heavy and the LA Times had already
committed at that point to write an
obituary of every Californian who died
in either theater and here's an example
of one and this if you start if you put
on what I call when I talk to the
normies your database glasses which I'm
sure there's no trouble for you guys and
you look at content like this from our
website you could begin to sort of guess
kind of what database fields and columns
are behind a system like this right
a new story like this will have a
headline right that'll be one column
they'll be like that little sub headline
sometimes called the deck head in
newspaper slang there's the publication
date that'll be a column that'll be
date-time format right and then what the
journalists think is the most important
column the byline all right with their
name and then in almost all news
databases after stuff like that there's
just another one that's just the big
blob of text right which is all the
English that we put into it just as one
big crazy blob of text and when I had
arrived the LA Times had already written
hundreds of obituaries just like that of
each person and I was looking for a data
project to hook to start off with and I
was looking for people to hook up with
and we decided what if we were to build
the database of these obituaries rather
than just publish them as big blobs of
text and forget about them and if you
keep those database glasses on and you
begin to read a story like this you can
see the other columns that would be very
easy to fill in for many of these like
if we just look at the lead here we can
see we have the person's branch
they're ranked their hometown how they
died where they died right first middle
last name age high school right
marital status number of kids that had a
gender right go on and on all those
things could be classified and so what
we did is we pulled out all that what
would you guys call it in your slang
labels or categories I just call them
columns or fields right okay good I'm
learning a lot of jargon here today my
favorite so far is fraud II if something
has like a high score on the fraud
system and so Malloy more on our team
who actually is a veteran herself and an
educated librarian did that basically
and we used another open-source system
that I don't hear as much about in this
conference but is essential to us which
is would anyone know what this is Django
it's the Django I mean you can't wait
twice it's the Django as a web framework
that it's kind of from the website of
Python that was actually invented at the
lawrence journal world newspaper and was
used to launch websites ultimately like
instagram pinterest and many others use
it as like a framework for development
on the back end but one of the great
features of it is as an instant admin so
if you design a database table that has
like the columns we were just talking
about it will create this generic admin
with no code from you it can just like
infer it and do it and for what we do
which is often assembling databases that
don't exist before out of the news right
a system like this to get a data entry
platform like up and running is just
huge right and so we put this is it we
built the system and here's that same
guy in the same story first middle last
name gender age unique slug hometown and
when we had done that and assembled for
all of them were able to do a lot more
we were able to build a website that had
a page for every single person and you
could click the link of the hometown and
you could see everyone who's died from
that hometown and we could publish these
pages before the obituaries were
finished get the page out there on the
web early get comments from people who
knew them on the page and in turn turn
that data into a product it's not just a
traditional story but also after you've
accrued it you're also to then able to
mine that database you've you've created
for all sorts of enterprise stories one
we're counting them we know when the 500
person died we can integrate population
data and tell you what hometown has had
the most deaths per capita we could tell
you what cemetery has the most guys
buried at it and then we can go write a
Memorial Day story there and we can take
a more structured and you know numerate
approach to how we do a lot of
traditional stuff right and that's
because we took the news and we turned
it into the database that didn't exist
another example of that is the homicide
report at homicide at LA Times comm
which is the database that's kept by a
few people on our team mainly Nicole
Santa Cruz who's like that correspondent
and writer who does a lot of it and the
iris Lee who does a lot of the computer
programming web development stuff and
that also has a Django admin where we're
taking the source data which is just a
list of people who've been killed from
the county coroner's office and we're
enriching that you know we only give us
a couple data columns really not a lot
we're putting that in and then we're
adding more and more stuff from our
reporting and we're accruing over time
this this sort of unique original
database about everyone who's been
killed by another person and in the same
way we can we can use Django and a
templated web framework to build a page
for every every person including this
guy who you probably don't know this
person who you probably don't know but
you should and this person you
definitely do know right and so the
templating system and using even the
sparse data we have to push it out
through the system allows us to create a
page for every single person who's died
which sadly in many cases is the only
notice of the the murder of many of
these people there's so little coverage
and then it becomes the kind of a
baseline from which we can try to reach
and do more elevated and insightful work
a recent example would be this story
Nicole did about all the people who died
from street racing in LA County which is
actually a lot of people where we took
our homicide report data we connected it
with some other data we did and we were
able to analyze what happens and like
one key finding here is that the
majority of people who do this who died
in these cases actually are passengers
they're not the drivers which is said
you read the story it's good and that
also is a Jupiter notebook that you can
get
and besides stories we also take the
news and turn it into software which
then turns into more stories so like we
were doing a lecture
results you know the live election
results you see on election night and
all the fancy maps and charts in every
news organization this was ours from the
California primary and every single one
of those pages on every single news site
you look at the data all comes from the
same source The Associated Press so you
don't have to worry about thinking once
faster than the other better than the
other they're all the exact identical
source that everybody pays in for and
that data service actually has some open
source wrappers built around it here's
one we built a few years ago which was
then succeeded by this and this is a
case of people in our news nerd world
collaborating around the common problems
we have which are often gnarly datasets
you know what I mean and gnarly datasets
that need to be like refined and worked
on and turned into data pipelines are
like the number one need in our news
nerd world for open source to help solve
problems so that we can collaborate to
get it done like you know and so here's
La County's crappy site the AP doesn't
have LA County results LA County has
this site which you might think oh it
could be worse Ben but then you crack
open the data file and here it is it's
not just a fixed-width file it's a
fixed-width file with different widths
depending on what type of line that
you're on and so Anthony Pesci and our
team did the miserable work of like
actually figuring out how to parse that
file to do that whatever you would call
a variable fixed width or whatever that
is and then we just yesterday released
that as an open source library so that
hopefully nobody else has to do that
like gnarly parse again and when we have
to do it again in two years we'll
remember because we like put it into a
package right and if you're interested
in our open source work I made another
repo data desk slash packages which has
the more than 30 open source
repositories that our team has put out
and maintains you'll notice that a
really large majority of them have to do
with dealing with gnarly data sets that
we go to a lot and then those that those
packages often then turn into stories so
like anybody know what this side is
what's in it though what's on it what's
in here now now not this this one but
this is called Cal access anybody ever
been here this is my least favorite
website campaign-finance so all the
money that goes into the governor's race
and all the propositions and all the
State House races as opposed to Congress
and the federal stuff all the state
races all that all that money is
reported into an awful database kept by
the Secretary of State called Cal access
and this is a really important database
but nobody does any analysis of it
because it's a it's a mess it's a it's
awful right and so that's where we
created this group the California civic
data coalition to create a github
pipeline that would then take that data
and you know and smooth it out and
format it into something that's usable
and this is an ongoing project we have
with more than 150 contributors around
the world and it's resulted in this
still improving website where we create
clean documented CSVs that like a normal
person can just pull down the source
data from the government is eighty-eight
tables 35 million records no
documentation about 40 the tables are
defunct never been labeled the joins are
all screwed it's such a mess so we're
trying to solve that and because we've
got that far and we have these
simplified versions it's helping Ryan
and Malloy who you saw earlier team with
people like Seema Mehta one of our
political reporters to do more stories
about money in politics that are more
ambitious analysis than would have been
done because if you got to spend six
months doing the analysis you're only
gonna get that one story and do it again
the next time it's gonna take six months
again but we've reduced like the barrier
to getting into that data and we're
trying to more and more which has allow
us to do stories like Gavin Newsom being
the first guy to really take money from
pot do a dashboard of all the money
coming into the state state state yeah
the governor's race that updates really
frequently then mining that for analysis
like being able to point out this that
the charter schools really put a lot of
money into V Ragosa and the primary
being able to do historical analysis to
show that that money from those outside
groups was the most ever you know and
giving that kind of context requires
having all that data at hand and then
more recently mining into every campaign
donation Gavin Newsom are likely next
governor
has ever received to do kind of a story
about his his his him coming in and so
California or at California civic data
dot o-r-g is where that's at and this is
kind of our biggest project right now of
trying to bring people together to solve
a common data problem I've got tons of
problems and tickets and stuff in there
if anyone's interested in money in
politics this is a great place to get
involved there's other money in politics
things to get involved with too if you
curious just come talk to me I'm running
out of time our team does other stuff
like BOTS and tools and toys and other
[ __ ] but that's the end because I'm
out of time you can follow us at these
links and again all the slides are at
this URL and that's that's all I got if
you got questions holler
so does anyone have any questions
well that's an interesting question
so the question is whether the click
rate difference between interactive and
static graphics and this is a hot topic
in the world of data visualization you
guys may remember like in the time of
Flash graphics you know and when data
visualization really took off everything
had lots of hovers and boxes and things
that jumped around and doodads dancing
bears is what Tom to Iraq at the New
York Times used to call them and
recently as the Internet's move more
toward mobile phones you may be noticing
the graphics from high-end visit people
tend to be like just flat images you
don't I mean because they know you're on
your phone and they think it's less
likely you're gonna interact there's a
little bit of a dispute about like the
actual numbers behind that cuz I don't
think there's been a serious study but
obviously the majority of people
visiting LA Times comm and every new
site are now doing it on a phone right
and so whatever you make it has to work
on a phone and has to be good on a phone
we can do things that are good on both
that are they're simplified on the phone
and are progressively enhanced on
desktop right which is what we try to do
but you can't over invest in the desktop
and in the desktop doodads my feeling is
is that the interactivity is great and
we don't want to lose it but it's got to
be it's got to be awesome you know what
I mean the thing that it does the thing
that the dancing bear has to be a really
good dancing bear for it to be worth the
investment
sure
virtual reality we've done a couple
virtual reality experiments I don't know
if we've like invested a ton maybe maybe
not you know I think there's some people
who think VR is the future of
storytelling and there's some people who
don't I don't know the answer to that I
think VR is really cool you know I mean
we've done some things that I'm really
proud of one of my former colleagues
armando mangia made did a VR tour of
Mars of the area where the Mars rover
had like crawled around and you can like
fly around and it more than anything
I've ever experienced it really helped
me understand the terrain of Mars you
know so I thought it was an awesome like
experience as we say in our business
sorry but whether it's gonna be the
future of news as we also say in our
business I don't know
we'll find out
well you know it's the newsroom is just
a collection of people you know they
mean and what's that oh it's question
was are there some people in the
newsroom who are less open to working
with data right is that your question of
some sections I don't think that Eddie
you know I hate to generalize you know
as often as I do but no I think you know
it just kind of comes down to the person
you know our kind of general philosophy
is we want to work with people who want
to work with us and so we tend to seek
out a partner people who like want to
have that relationship and we're lucky
to be in a situation where our job is
just to be like a catalyst just like
make a cool story app and make like a
thing happen and if we do that we're
good so we don't have to like break down
walls or deal with people who don't want
to deal with us which is a great thing
about our set up in my opinion I got a
question please so that that story you
open with it's kind of it's easy to
connect with in common with this
populist level like the fat cat getting
the huge property discount because
they're weird pets or whatever but I'm
wondering how often you guys run across
stories that I mean the end of the day
LA Times is still a business I'm
wondering how often you guys run across
the story that you feel like this is
interesting and it's worthwhile but we
got to kind of self select out because
it's not gonna generate that clicks that
we need to drive I'm never consciously
you know what I mean that's never like a
thing where we know we can't do this
story no one will read it that's never
happened you know I'm sure there is in
like the collection of humans and
institutions some sort of subconscious
or institutional bias around whatever
like why do we write more about the
Lakers than the Clippers you know what I
mean more people care about the Lakers
you know there are definitely things
like that no offense to Ryan who's a
Clippers fan but but no I've never in my
entire journalistic career had anyone
say we can't do a good story because
people aren't interested in it one cool
thing about newsrooms is it's definitely
full of people who are on the watch for
stuff like that and are paranoid about
it and also no one wants to get in the
way of a good story in a newsroom if you
got a good story everyone will be
supportive which is one of the cool
things about being in the newsroom hello
thanks for talking I want to hear about
a time when you made a decision - I'm
back sensor data or like not share
certain information that right under how
you think about yeah right so in this
case
actually put the whole property tax role
with the names up there because I felt
like it would it's it's standard
practice in other counties and it's
ridiculous that it's not public I can
look it up online in most places in
America and I just kind of wanted to
make the point and so I did it even
though no one will notice but there's
definitely other cases where we don't
because there's just no reason right if
and it could potentially backfire on the
story if P if that becomes a distraction
from what you're trying to tell so for
instance one piece of public data that
is public that is rarely published
online is voter registration data so how
you vote is totally secret nobody knows
how you vote but if you're registered to
vote and in what party and whether you
vote yes or no is a public record and
the political parties are using this
data and getting it from the Secretary
of State all the time right and we did a
story about a weird third party called
the American independent party which was
formed by George Wallace to get on the
ticket in the 60s here in California and
there's thousands and thousands of
people including the new owner of the LA
Times by the way who accidentally
registered in this party thinking it was
being independent but you were actually
joining the American independent party
oopsey right and so we did a story about
that whole oopsie and we made a look up
so you could check am I in this like
crazy party that I don't want to be in
and it would return like yes or no if
you put your stuff in but I didn't like
surface the whole database so that
everybody could look up everybody else I
put a little birthdate checker on there
even though you wouldn't have to because
I didn't want it to turn into a fishing
expedition I wanted to make it more of a
service for readers and I thought that
could distract from the story so that's
a case where we it's an editorial
judgment you know totally legally we
could have published it but it just
didn't fit with what our goals was we're
in publishing does that make sense okay
so data science is really hot right now
yeah how are you can what is your like
value add in the job market are you
paying big salaries or is it just like
all the work is like really rewarding or
do you just say Ryan oh geez raises hell
yes we definitely could use a raise you
know what I mean we're in a business
that's collapsing let's be honest right
and and so there there's there's a
little bit of a premium for what we do
but not so much
that they're out there throwing a lot of
money around you know the reality is is
almost everyone I know who does what
like we do are people who have like have
have some of these skills that you guys
have or have an interest in them but
aren't like SuperDuper skilled but we're
passionate about journalism and we kind
of like you kind of see like wow if I
learn these skills that I do this stuff
we can do these cool stories that we
wouldn't otherwise do we can make the
news better we can do better stuff you
know and so for us it I think for most
people it kind of fits the two things
kind of go together your passion for
news and your interest or maybe passion
for programming and stuff help you like
push together and there definitely are
people who do what we do who now work
I'd one of my guard in 2007 the guy who
got hired the same day he works at a
hedge fund now right and I know people
who work in mergers and acquisitions and
thought out of that and I but that's not
for me I wish you paid better maybe one
day I'm trying to rewrite our job
descriptions we'll see how that goes I
give you some tips on that by the way if
anyone's in a unionized newsroom or a
workplace yeah so I have a question
about the alternative facts news or fake
news fake news right well it's sort of a
two-part question first of all do you
see the role of the press in trying to
limit identify report on or debunk fake
news that are being spread around there
through most common with social media
channels and do you guys work did you
guys do any work in that in that area
specifically our team hasn't
specifically worked on that but I had my
opinion there's been a lot of great data
journalism about fake news like I've the
story I feel like really caught on that
seemed him as far as I know was was well
done was the BuzzFeed news story by
Craig Silverman about how the most
shared stories before the last election
that you know that we're all fake you
know what I mean like the Pope endorsing
Trump or whatever and that was a case
where he took his data journalism skills
and he took it at this sort of inside
the media topic and I thought it had an
impact and in my opinion I think the
media coverage about fake news the real
news about the fake news
has drawn a lot of attention to this
problem which i think is good you know
and I'm all for people doing that you
know I I hear about not being an expert
I hear about research that says when you
debunk false claims you just reinforce
those claims and a lot of people's minds
there's like behavioral research on this
I'm not an expert and it makes me worry
that maybe we're not helping things you
know but I don't I don't have the
solution and as a journalist you know
kind of my default assumption is always
more sunlight is better more coverage is
better and so I'm all for it and I think
there's been a lot of great technology
people who've helped news organizations
cover that story too so ok last question
you can bug me afterwards too ok my
question is oh sorry yeah my question is
can you talk a little bit about the data
desk rolls and how you go from
collecting data is that a specific role
to somebody who's building the website
and and producing the visualizations we
don't really have like like firmly
design defined roles like oh you're the
designer and you're the database
administrator and you're the writer you
know what I mean
maybe we should do that but my feeling
is on our team we're better off when
everybody is kind of a generalist when
everybody is really comfortable I just
say people on our team when we're
looking for like young people to break
in I don't care if you can code I care
if you can like solve problems you know
what I mean and if you're creative about
solving problems with computers and to
me that's like the essential skill of
like what we're doing is being a hard
worker who's creative it like doing that
and the result is is we have a team it's
kind of like a pretty odd ball crew of
people who have like different skills
like Ryan's who's here came through a
statistics program Malloy came through
the army right and libraries we have
other people who came through
traditional journalism schools and other
routes and we have some people who are
better at HTML and CSS and JavaScript
and other people who are better at
Python but they learn from each other
and just kind of we just kind of make it
make stuff happen you know so we don't
define it that much we might need to if
we want to get paid more though huh and
but no we don't thank you yep oh we
could you want to do more questions Oh
more questions I could talk all night
guys I have a question
have you noticed yeah can I ask you a
question yeah please
oh thanks I'm right here okay so last
night I saw the soloist oh and I would
not have known who's Steve Lopez
two days ago yeah so that was cool that
you mentioned him that is a really
wonderful movie and it's all about this
very kind of human story this
idiosyncratic random meeting between two
people which leads to this that's right
big thing I was curious you know you
mentioned the future of journalism
you're talking about data journalism
here do you see the the methods you're
talking about potentially growing and
importance as they most certainly will I
think but when they do do you think that
they could potentially wind up
displacing or replacing the kind of
human journalism stories that we well
said we're movie I don't know you know
what I mean I mean you guys are the you
know machine learning people you can
educate me about how far computers are
going to get at writing stories you know
what I mean like the one bit of like
automated news writing that our team has
done is is related to quakes earthquakes
so there's like a automatic there's data
that gets sent out every time the
government detects an earthquake and one
of my colleagues wrote a bot that
automatically writes a blog post about
every earthquake that just has like the
basic data and like a map and then that
gets sent to the copy desk every time
the quake happens we call quake BOTS and
that's the sort of thing a lot of people
look at and they say jibon you're you're
killing you're stealing our jobs you
know what I mean but the reality is in
my opinion is that the jobs are already
gone
you know the LA Times is one third of
the size of was if you look at the
Bureau of Labor Statistics numbers the
number of people who work in newspapers
is is 50% what it was 10 or 15 years ago
like literally the industry is
disappearing and that's because of the
change in the advertising model and the
shift to the internet and the increased
competition and all these other things
that have to be honest nothing to do
with the automation of content creation
and everything to do with the automation
of content delivery and distribution
right and that's really what's changed
our industry and I feel like that's kind
of boring and everybody loves the
internet you know
because it's awesome and so it's not as
exciting to talk about as like the
computers gonna write the story instead
but those those quake posts that the bot
is doing nobody was doing them you know
what I mean it's not replacing anybody
it's doing something we weren't doing
and it's relieving the people who worked
there from having to like scramble and
write a little post every time their
editor feels an earthquake great as
opposed to doing an automated way so I
think that we are the industries it's
such a crisis and in such a deep thing a
change I don't see that as having a huge
effect you know maybe you know I think
sure like data cleaning like I spend
most of my time doing as I tried to show
on that maybe you guys can automate that
work away for me please do you know what
I mean I don't want to do that yeah so
because of the journalists and like
industry is so rough right now I'm
curious if you have any like if you've
experienced any pushback on making
things open-source and just kind of
sharing this with other journalists
versus you know keeping some of these
things private and in-house so that the
LA Times has a monopoly on certain types
of stories now nobody's really paying
attention I'll be honest with you and
and I and if they when they do I'm kind
of ready to make the case you know you
look at something like that election
stuff I went over really really fast but
that's a case where we would have spent
weeks and weeks and weeks writing the
same code that everybody else was
writing you know what I mean and
everybody's team is two or three or four
or five people and we just don't have
the resources to like do all this stuff
on our own I don't think there's really
a choice other than open source to solve
a lot of the problems we have because we
just don't have a hundred engineers to
throw it anything you know and so
there's really only a couple places that
can really have a competitive advantage
of this and they're the largest ones and
if you're in a small or midsize place I
think open source is your only only real
opportunity now that said they're you
know what's the old Linux thing Fudd
you know fear uncertainty and doubt
people raised about open source that
definitely happens there was a long
period of time where we had a lawyer who
just like didn't like open source for
some reason so I just didn't put
licenses on our repo because I just
didn't want to have a conversation with
a lawyer about a license I just put and
I get pull requests from the license
nerd saying you should they had a
license and I was like yeah I'm just not
gonna do that
you know because because I don't want to
have to defend that to the lawyer one
day you know day mean and then she she
left and now I put licenses on
it's MIT guys I'm into MIT I don't know
about you I thank you so much for coming
and speaking today thank you in the back
my question is what is the current
vision for the times and how are you
gonna make the stories reach us and many
other folks of our generation who have
kind of split off I know that I noticed
that you guys have hired for podcasts
and that's one way but what's the vision
and how are you reaching us well that's
above my pay grade and still being
developed the LA Times has a new owner
his name is dr. Patrick soon Xian he is
one of the richest people in Los Angeles
and the richest doctor in the world he
made his money on pharmaceuticals a and
other things and now he's in his 60s and
he's bought the LA Times as kind of a
legacy project for himself though he
says he intends to run it fully as the
business and not as a philanthropy and
so as of just a few months ago we're an
entirely different ownership structure
and fiscal situation than we were for
the the 20 years that preceded him right
and what that's gonna mean for us is an
independent like thing owned by a single
billionaire is still unclear you know
and that strategy we have a new editor
we're hiring for the first time in a
long time which is great I'm more
optimistic about some things than I have
been in a while which is good but what
it's ultimately gonna mean I don't know
you know I think if we follow the trends
of the rest of the industry it probably
means moving toward more towards a
digital subscription model because
digital advertising doesn't pay and it's
failing for pretty much everyone and so
in order to finance the news
organization the readers have to pay
more right and so that's why everyone's
going to pay walls and that kind of
thing and that's been very successful
for a few places so I suspect well we're
gonna invest more than that but even
that really hasn't been announced I
think it's still being determined in El
Segundo as we speak I'll be watching as
closely as you trust me all right I
think I have the last one okay I get the
last question twice in a row okay can I
so one of my biggest pet peeves is poor
scientific journalism I'm wondering if
the data desk provide
it's for the LA Times some statistical
expertise for pieces and and kind of
what you guys what is your guys's role
in that we do when called upon and we
try to on the stories we work on
directly but it's not like there's a
desk that every story comes by and we
stamp it yes yes the math is right and I
like you have picked up the paper some
day and been like I don't know about
using percentage change right there you
know what I mean or whatever right and
or is it billion or million are we sure
you know like that kind of thing and
there isn't like a centralized process
for that we have editors and copy
editors and people who go over
everything really carefully but there's
not like a numbers editor who looks at
every number in the paper that's managed
kind of on a story by story basis and so
that we don't could be exhausting if I
did be honest
thank you okay I have a few lotto
tickets left
yeah I'm trying to think of a fair way
to give these out what's that okay yeah
we could use them right definitely true
how about if you come up to me
afterwards and tell you tell me about an
LA Times story you read recently proving
you've read it I'll give you a lotto
ticket okay thank you
[Applause]